gut meine damen und herren schönen abend
mein name ist markus der logan hatten
sich für die messe sprecher der polizei
in münchen
wie wir gerade im hintergrund gehört
haben bin ich froh dass sie nach diesem
o-ton ihre handys wieder einschalten
ich kann ihnen momentan nur einen ersten
stand geben der sich momentan so
darstellt dass wir gegen 17 58 hier aus
dem oez die ersten notrufe bekommen
haben da war die rede von einem
schusswechsel
wir haben relativ schnell einsatzkräfte
heranführen können auch kräfte des
rettungsdienstes in der folge konnten
wir dann feststellen dass es diesen
schusswechsel tatsächlich gegeben hat
wir fahnden momentan nach bis zu drei
tätern haben aktuell gesichert fünf
personen die offensichtlich infolge
dieses ereignisses verstorben sind und
haben darüber hinaus mehrere
schwerverletzte
im umfeld dieser tat wir hatten ja noch
zu geschäftsöffnungszeiten haben wir
natürlich jede menge augenzeugen so dass
wir im moment etwa 100 personen durch
die lokalen kriseninterventionsteams
betreuen lassen
und natürlich mit allem was wir momentan
an personal aufbringen können
mit großer unterstützung der umgebenden
verbände im großraum münchen in der
verhandlung sind ganz wichtig ist mir
folgende aussage sie werden das
sicherlich am rande mitbekommen haben
wir haben momentan relativ viele notrufe
die über eine entsprechende wie auch
immer geartete bedrohung soder
gefährdungslage an anderen schauplätzen
in der stadt berichten
dem gehen wir natürlich mit großem
engagement und mit sehr viel
kräfteeinsatz nach müssen aber bislang
feststellen dass sich diese zweiten
schauplätze so dieser form nicht
bestätigt haben dass jetzt erst mal
aktuell zulage
das ist tatsächlich viel zu früh um eine
aussage zu treffen
momentan keine kunden mehr alles noch
sehr frisch
ich könnte ihnen diese auskunft
beantworten wenn wir die schon mal
hätten aber daran habe ich gerade gesagt
5 das ist auch alles noch recht früh
jetzt ist alle allererste priorität
natürlich priorität natürlich die
tatortaufnahme dann geht der nächste
schritt natürlich dahingehend dass man
die person erst mal vernünftig
zertifizieren muss angehörigen
verständigung und ganz zum schluss
kommen sie dran wenn jemand mit einem
mit einer langwaffe das ist die erste
meldung gewesen in ein einkaufszentrum
geht und ich mich dann einfach mal ein
bisschen zurück innere was die letzten
wochen und europa passiert ist denke ich
ist es gerechtfertigt in diesem
zusammenhang von dieser
schlimmstmögliche annahme auszugehen
und das ist auch gut so dass wir davon
ausgegangen sind wir haben in den
notrufen den hinweis auf langwaffen das
ist richtig das kann ich ihnen
tatsächlich nicht genau sagen lassen sie
mich einfach das so zusammenfassen sehr
sehr viele die kommen natürlich einmal
aus dem bereich des pp münchen aber die
struktur der bayerischen polizei ist so
aufgebaut dass wir gerade in solchen
einsatzlagen durch die nachbar verbände
sehr schnell eine verstärkung
organisieren und realisieren können das
hat hervorragend funktioniert so dass
wir tatsächlich mit ausreichend polizei
im stadtgebiet unterwegs sind
die täter sind nach unserem jetzigen
stand wir gehen aktuell von bis zu drei
tätern aus es gibt aber widersprüchliche
angaben
aber bis zu drei tätern zur zeit auf der
flucht da kann ich ihm momentan keine
auskunft zu geben
dann kann ich leider nicht langwaffe
bedeutet halt länger als eine pistole
eine das wäre eine kurzwaffe also
vermutlich gewehr oder vergleichbar
aber das ist spekulativ regionen in
welchen regionen suchen sie nach den
tätern im gesamten stadtgebiet weil wir
sehr schnell sind und im zuge dieser
maßnahmen natürlich auch nicht nur in
münchen sondern auch in der umgebung
umfangreiche fahndungsmaßnahmen kraft
gesetzt haben
das ist eine sehr wichtige informationen
ich hoffe dass sie diese information am
ende auch mit uns teilen weil wir
natürlich im rahmen unserer ermittlungen
um jede information dankbar sind wir
werden im zuge der heutigen nacht auch
das so genannte upload portal des
landeskriminalamtes aktivieren um
entsprechende videos dann auch
einsammeln zu können
das ist eine der maßnahmen die wir
konzeptionell vorbereitet haben und sind
letzten endes der sicherheit der
bevölkerung
wir haben ein hervorragendes sek
die habe ich gesehen ob es ob die gsg9
hier ist das kann ich so nicht
bestätigen